hey you guys time for another movie
retrospective now normally Tom would be
doing this uh retrospective with me but
he didn't get around to seeing this
movie and after I saw it I kind of
figured it wasn't really his bag anyway
so I was kind of like whatever I'll just
you know it I had to get it recorded
today so I was like whatever [ __ ] it
I'll just like uh do it on my own and so
that's what we're gonna do hopefully
that's not gonna be a problem for
anybody but you know here we go so
1932's vampire or vompier if you want to
pronounce it like all [ __ ] fancy and
European it's one of those movies that
I always felt like I needed to get
around to seeing as it's one that often
turns up on lists of like most
influential horror films of all time or
conversely like lists of influential
horror films that not that many people
have seen like they're very underrated
or under scene or whatever now um I will
admit that this movie is a lot less I
guess straightforward and a lot more
experimental than many of these sort of
more iconic Universal horror films that
came out around the same era like in the
1930s that most horror fans will be
familiar with there is something that's
actually really kind of
nightmarish about this particular movie
it has a very bizarre sort of like
disjointed narrative and these really
creepy surreal visuals and it really
just kind of has like a whole unsettling
mood to it even though
um I'm gonna admit that it's not always
entirely clear what exactly is going on
and I actually had to go read the
Wikipedia plot synopsis to make sure
that I got all the [ __ ] because I was
just kind of like wait what does that
mean that like you know what I mean so
it's a little bit like that so this was
directed by the Danish auteur Carl
Theodore Dreyer uh who at the time that
this was made was already kind of like
you know very famous very celebrated for
his 1928 classic film The Passion of
Joan of Arc which some people have
called one of the greatest movies of all
time
um but the thing about vampire was it
had a really complicated and troubled
production history which is actually
like to me I found like um just as
interesting as the movie itself so
Dreyer and his writer collaborator whose
name was Kristen Jewell or Ewell they
wrote the script and it was based on two
novellas by Sheridan Le fanu and it was
two novellas that turned up in his 1872
collection which was called in a glass
Darkly which actually had five stories
in it like three short stories and two
novellas so one of the novellas that
this was based on was the famous lesbian
vampire story uh carmilla which
obviously is a classic and has been made
into movies a bunch of times and the
other one was more like a mystery that
was called the room in the dragon Volant
uh which was kind of centered around a
premature burial so he wanted to do
something with vampires and also with
premature burial like I said so those
two stories they kind of took elements
of those and kind of like wove a
narrative around it so I guess Dreyer
wanted to make a vampire movie in
particular because the 1927 Stage
production of Dracula had been you know
so wildly successful and so vampires
were kind of consequently a hot
commodity like in entertainment at the
time so he started working on what would
become vampire in 1929 and it was going
to be his first movie with sound though
because it was his first movie with
sound he wasn't really all that
confident in his ability to successfully
make the transition from silent film so
kind of to compromise on that vampire is
largely silent anyway it's kind of like
it does have some dialogue in it but not
very much so it might as well be a
silent film The People barely talk like
they do kind of say stuff and there are
sound effects and things like that but
it even has like the title cards like
explaining what's going on like a silent
film would have and it is for all
intents and purposes it might as well be
a silent film because there's really not
much dialogue in it now the actors uh
actually mouved the minimal dialogue in
three different languages English French
and German and then they were going to
dub like with other voice actors like in
post-production so they could release it
on different continents but it doesn't
appear as far as I'm aware that the
English language version was ever
finished or it was lost or something
like that the print that I actually
ended up watching which was on HBO Max
and that was like the Criterion
Collection version uh was actually in
German with English subtitles and
English title cards like every time
writing appears on the screen it's in
English but apparently the I don't know
if they never did like an English dubbed
version but this was the German one so
I'm not really sure if the English
language one is available it just had
English subtitles this movie also has a
cast of almost entirely non-actors some
of them were just like spotted on like
in a cafe or on a train or something
like that and they were like hey you
look kind of like the character that
we're looking for so hey I want to be in
a movie so there's that now the main
character sort of uh who is this
traveler guy like by the name of Alan
gray that's his character's name in the
movie is actually played by a very
wealthy French socialite and magazine
editor whose name was Nicholas de
gunsberg and he was actually credited in
the movie Under a pseudonym Julian West
because he didn't want to embarrass his
prominent family who were really not
jazzed about him wanting to be an actor
so Carl Dreyer it seems uh was a lot
less concerned about narrative cohesion
let's say that and he was kind of more
into just he wanted to do something
different something that nobody was
doing he wanted to like break new ground
in cinema as a medium so in this
particular movie he uses kind of a lot
of really cool visual tricks like he
shot some of the outdoor scenes like
everything shot on location uh instead
of on a Sound Stage which was a little
bit unusual for the time I feel like and
he even shot a lot of the outdoor scenes
like through a piece of gauze like to
give it this kind of blurred
otherworldly look which actually kind of
happened by accident like when they were
doing some of the dailies I guess and he
saw them and it was kind of all like
fuzzy and Overexposed and he's like well
that's the look that I want so then they
figured out like to put gods in front of
the camera like to get that to replicate
that
um he also and I kind of I'm not like an
expert of movies from this era but I
feel like a lot of movies from this era
were very much like stage plays which
isn't surprising because that's they
were kind of making the transition so
you know they were basically just
filming plays so the camera to a large
extent kind of like stayed static like
stayed still while the action was going
on in front of it but this one has kind
of like some really interesting like
quick panning shots and stuff like that
which I don't believe I've ever seen
like I said I'm not an expert and I
haven't seen a [ __ ] ton of movies from
the late 1920s early 1930s but I don't
remember a lot of them having these kind
of like sweeping panning shots like this
one does
um he also plays a lot in this one with
like uh weird things with like shadows
and double exposures and things like the
ghosts and that kind of stuff so he was
kind of like pulling out all the stops
to make this look different to what
everyone else was doing at the time so
the movie was actually finished in 1931
but it got delayed the release of it was
delayed for nine months because
Universal wanted their Dracula and
Frankenstein to come out first whether
this was a factor in the way that
vampire was generally received uh isn't
really all that clear but what is very
clear is that the critics and the
audiences did not respond very favorably
to vampire to say the very least One
reviewer matter of fact called it one of
the worst films I have ever attended and
very famously at one showing members of
the audience demanded their money back
and then started a riot when they didn't
get it so this was very very
unsuccessful and was also a financial
failure and matter of fact the whole uh
chaos surrounding this and the whole
reaction to it being so negative
actually made uh Carl Dreyer have a
nervous breakdown and he had to be
hospitalized for a little while like
after this movie came out I mean
obviously though at at this stage
vampire has been you know has been given
a critical reassessment and is now
recognized for the influential classic
that it is I will say like watching it
is a lot like watching a really long bad
dream and
although I didn't find this quite as
impactful or as Eerie as something like
Nosferatu for example it still does have
like a really spooky kind of like
hypnotic power to it
um although I will say that even by
1930s standards it's very very slowly
paced it's not long it's only 73 minutes
but it does like take a while like some
of the scenes are really long so just
know that going in even if you're really
into 1930 cinema this might seem a
little uh the pace might seem a little
stately you know what I mean so as I
mentioned our main protagonist is a guy
named Alan gray who is a traveler they
just kind of call him a traveler and he
has an interest specifically says the
title card in devil worship and vampires
so he goes to this small French town
called cortem Pierre which is a real
place and he books a night at an inn but
shortly after going to bed even though
it's like the daytime but see the whole
thing takes place in the daytime even
though like when they're talking like
it's supposed to be night but I guess
that's because obviously they couldn't
really shoot at night back then but I
don't know it again it gives it like
this really weird like disembodied like
kind of displaced sort of feeling to it
so he goes to bed and not long after
that like this strange old dude just
kind of comes into his room just kind of
like looking at him and he just like
walks in the room and like he sits in
bed like what the [ __ ] is this like
looking all shocked and everything
and he just kind of like it's very very
unsettling so he comes in and he leaves
this little package like a little
rectangular package on the desk and then
he writes on it to be opened upon my
death
and then he leaves and like the only
thing that he says to Alan is she
mustn't die do you understand so this
whole thing this was a great setup and
this got me into the story like right
away because I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on here like I knew it was gonna
involve vampires you know what I mean in
some way but I just thought this was
like a really good suspenseful setup so
then there's this kind of like long
dream like sequence where Alan he kind
of first sees this old woman and this
old man who kind of looks like Albert
Einstein wandering around and they
actually well you don't know who they
are at first but they end up factoring
into the plot later on
and then he's evidently led to this
manor house by a bunch of Shadows but
they're like they're supposed to be
beings I guess people like weird
disembodied like shadow people but some
of them are doing like regular [ __ ] like
there's a party and there's like a bunch
of couples dancing like Shadows like
against the wall then like some of them
are like sitting on benches next to each
other like they just came from work or
something and then there's one guy who's
like digging a grave but it's happening
like in Reverse so like he's going like
that and like the dirt is I don't know
it's like really really weird looking so
he just sees all this kind of stuff and
I guess I didn't get this at the time
but like after I read a synopsis they're
like yeah these Shadows are like leading
him toward this particular manor house
like where he's supposed to go I didn't
really get that but like I said
this you know it's not like super super
clear what's going on so when he gets to
this manor house he sees the old man who
came in his room and left the package
but his Allen is kind of like knocking
on the door like looking in the window
like hey it's that guy there's like a
shadow person that's like he sees
against the window or against the wall
and he has like a rifle and he shoots
the old man so alar like you know Alan
is very alarmed and he runs into the
house to help the guy but it's too late
like the dude just like dies there on
the floor so the servants ask Alan to
stay there so he does and he finds out
that the dead old guy who's like the
Lord of The Manor I guess I think that's
the only name they give him uh frankly
so he has a daughter named Leone and
she's sick so because it's a vampire
movie uh you know what that means and I
think they actually do make a comment
about like the wounds are healing or the
wounds on her neck or something like
that so you know that like there's some
vampire Shenanigans going on
so because the old guy is dead and put
the message on the package oh open it on
my death he's like oh well score I guess
I can open this now so he opens the
package and it's a book about vampires
and he reads it and like some of the
servants read it at some points too and
like so they'll put like pages of the
book like up on the screen like for very
very long periods of time so like you
can read it but it's like way longer
than a normal person would like need to
read it because I'm like holy crap they
must have read really slow back then I
was like I read it six times like in the
time that it was on the screen but you
know what I mean now most of this stuff
that's in the book like is pretty
standard vampire stuff but I will admit
there was some lore in there that I
hadn't really heard before such as and I
thought this was kind of cool this
doesn't really factor into the story too
much I don't think but there was a thing
where um the ghosts have executed
criminals would be like vampire henchmen
and I was like oh that's kind of neat I
never like saw anything from that angle
and I thought that would kind of be a
good story on its own and then there was
another thing about vampires is like
coaxing their victims into committing
suicide so that they would like turn
Undead quicker which totally makes sense
and I don't really know why I never
heard that specific piece of lore before
and this part does actually factor into
the story later on sort of so Alan
actually agrees to a blood transfusion
because like the servants are like you
know hey can you help her out oh and um
Leone also has like a younger sister
named Giselle and they're like hey she
needs a blood transfusion so he's like
okay I'll help out so he gives a blood
blood transfusion and he's also thinking
of like her dead dad like coming in and
leaving him the book and saying don't
let her die you know what I mean so he's
like okay well I'm gonna help out but in
the course of staying in the house with
the family and the servants there's kind
of like like I said she has a sister
leonie has a sister too Giselle who's
younger but there's kind of like a
creepy scene where and I think that um
Stills for a matter even like on some
Prince of the uh you know some DVDs or
some posters or whatever where the older
sister Leone she's like looking at her
at her younger sister Giselle all like
she wants to suck her blood you know
what I mean like she looks all
bloodthirsty and like the face that
she's making is like really really
creepy so there's that but while he's
staying there Alan actually starts to
suspect that the Albert Einstein looking
dude who is actually the village doctor
and I think that's the only name they
ever give me he's just Village doctor
like in the credits they he starts to
think that he's up to some shady ass
business and is actually trying to
poison Leone uh presumably either
because he's the vampire and himself and
is like hey dice you can be a vampire
with me or is working for whoever is the
actual vampire so it turns out uh and
spoiler alert for a movie that's nine
decades old you guys uh to be the latter
thing so the real vampire is actually
the old woman that Alan saw earlier like
you know kind of out of context and her
name turns out to be Marguerite Chopin
now in the course of this sort of oddly
stilted and fractured struggle against
the villains Giselle actually ends up
getting kidnapped by the doctor at some
point like tied up somewhere and Alan
has this sort of weird there's this
weird sequence it's like he has like an
out of Body Experience where he sees
himself buried alive like by the doctor
and Marguerite like they're putting him
in a coffin and stuff I think this whole
sequence right here was like my favorite
in the whole movie because like it cuts
back and forth to Alan's like kind of
wide-eyed he has a great face by the way
he looks a little bit like HB Lovecraft
now that I'm thinking about it but he
has like these big big eyes you know
what I mean so he has like these his
Dead face is like in this peering
through the glass window on top of his
coffin and so it cuts back and forth
from that to the perspective that he
would see like if he was laying in the
coffin like being carried out of the
church and like to the graveyard so he's
like seeing everything from below like
he can see the sky and like the tops of
the trees and he can see like the doctor
like leaning over him and like putting
the sales in and [ __ ] like that it's
really good it's like really really well
done
um and it's kind of like filmed through
this little kind of small aperture so it
looks like you're looking out like
through the top of the coffin and I
thought that was like really cool and it
goes on for a while but and I was not
entirely sure I'm like wait is this
really happening or is he just like
having a dream but it's like he's having
like a dreamer premonition or something
like that but it's really really
effective so everything gets sorted out
in the end um Alan wakes up from his
weird like Daydream and ends up helping
a servant like steak margarite with an
iron bar like they crack open her big
like gravestone and like put an iron bar
through her chest uh Giselle gets who
got kidnapped earlier she gets found and
she gets rescued and the Ghost of the
old guy who got shot earlier the one
that left the book and everything he
kind of um yeah like when his ghost
appears it's like this big face like in
the window which actually looks really
cool I thought it was like really really
uh creepily done and actually his ghost
somehow like disembodiedly like kills
one of the other henchmen like there was
this soldier that was working with them
too and he just like kills him and he's
all [ __ ] up on the stairs and then
also like chases the Albert Einstein
looking Doctor guy out of the house so
like the doctor ends up running to this
Mill and uh the hero servant I think
it's the same servant that like staked
the vampire locks the doctor like in
this little chamber and then like opens
up the the thing and like all the flower
falls on him and like suffocates him now
apparently this wasn't the original
ending they were gonna have the doctor
like either like I think he was supposed
to drown in a swamp in the original
version of the script but then when they
were scouting locations and they saw
this Mill and they were kind of like oh
my God that Mill's awesome we like we
need to do something with that so they
decided to like suffocate him in the
flower just so they could use the mill
in the movie but there is like a little
bit of a thing at the end like after
Allen and um and Giselle like get away
and they kind of like get in a boat and
whatnot but yeah they kind of but I like
the flower thing better it's just kind
of like more horrific I think that in
the German version of the film they
actually kind of cut that because they
thought it was too scary which like I
said nowadays it's like not it's nothing
but back then they were probably
probably like freaking out like somebody
being suffocated by a bunch of flour
which is kind of like a horrible death
if you think about it so I mean if you
have any interest at all in the
foundations of horror cinema this is
definitely one that you probably should
see like before you die not gonna lie as
I mentioned earlier it's very very slow
it's not a long movie it's only 73
minutes and I will say too that a lot of
times you don't really have a solid
handle on what's happening because it's
kind of like surreal like I said the
whole sequence with him seeing all the
shadow people I didn't really get that
the shadow people were leading him to
this house where he was supposed to go
like he was faded to do that and I only
got that like later after I was like
reading other like synopsis of it
instead of like oh okay that makes sense
but it wasn't like super clear in the
course of the movie some of the things
are but you know not so much other
things but I will say like the visuals
are really really creepy really
effective and like I said sort of
surreal and the movie kind of has this
real good like just this whole mood of
unease that's like permeating the
proceedings even when even when not much
is really going on it was actually like
a fascinating experiment for the time
for sure and it's really an intriguing
contrast to the more you know the less
ambiguous and maybe more crowd-pleasing
like Universal monster movies that more
people are familiar with so if you're
into experimental Cinema or you know
silent film or anything like that
because like I said this isn't
technically a silent film but it might
as well be because there's only there's
just a handful of uh lines of dialogue
in it and most of the rest of it is set
up like a silent film but if you're at
all interested in that and you haven't
seen this then it's probably one that
you should uh you know kind of put on
your list to see before you die because
it's kind of an important film in the
history of horror Cinema so that will do
it for this movie retrospective hope you
enjoyed it and I will see you guys again
on the next one bye
foreign